well we caught up with the director of
dieter today to discuss the number of
unemployment claims that were flagged
never paid out as well as the total
number of applications for unemployment
for the entire year that number
two million
[Music]
that two million number of applications
that came in that was over the course of
uh almost a year in both programs
so we did we did see almost half a
million sort of
initial unemployment claims that we were
expecting we
they just kept coming in
and and then to break it down then which
percentage of those
did you determine were fraudulent claims
so if you so if you just think about
that sort of number we were expecting
half a million folks to apply and be um
you know legitimate claimants and
that they didn't all necessarily meet
the criteria because they're fairly
stringent criteria
to be qualified for unemployment but
that was what we were expecting so
there were definitely
well over a million claims that just
never made it even into sort of getting
processed and they were identified as
fraud is a specific very legal term in
unemployment that you have to go through
a process so they were basically
identified as
imposters people who had stolen
identities
uh or information from stolen identities
and a lot of those were flagged as
imposter claims
and never paid like there were well over
a million that were never paid
uh what is being done to continue to
investigate those fraudulent claims that
do come in elisa
so there are a couple of uh there are a
couple of layers and and we've said all
along our focus really is
on trying to get eligible folks paid the
benefits that they're
qualified and eligible for and so that's
really been the focus
um and you know we we sort of try and
reach out to folks a lot of times to see
you know can you show us your
identification
can you give us some backup
documentation that was a lot of
the issues that we needed we
have put in place some security measures
that folks are familiar with like id me
that's a third party
um uh business that i
that verifies identities and they're
used by
i think over 20 states are using them
now and the federal government uses them
so
it's a pretty consistent you know
way to approve folks identification
elisa adds that they are working with
the federal government and the u.s
attorney's office on those imposter
claims these are the duplicate
applications filed in our state as well
as many others across the country
she says it will take years to assemble
those cases